[Musik]
mindestalter 18 jahre warum gilt das bei
der bundeswehr bisher nur für die
ausrüstung ist so eine gute antwort ja
klar geht sie was die antwort klage zu
gute antwort ja bei der ausrüstung liegt
einfach daran dass wir die bundeswehr
jahre kaputt gespart haben deswegen ist
die ausrüstung zu alt und das junge
leute mit 17 drei viertel da jetzt
anfangen ihren wehrdienst zu leisten
habe ich kein problem mit ehrlich gesagt
zumal derzeit hat noch eine wirklich
gegeben als ich dann auch mal eine 15
monate gemacht und nachhinein
ich habe nicht darunter gelitten das
sieht man ja auch an oder sind bei der
csu also schaden haben sich schon genau
ich habe zivildienst geleistet und habe
dabei fotokopierer repariert haben sie
ausgedient
natürlich werde ich verrückt redlich mit
dem da nicht gewinnst der weiß wovon er
spricht ja auch nicht gibt es von den
grünen ich habe fotos öffentlich
rechtlicher rundfunk der erwarten ist
dass ich mich jetzt ja aber da kümmere
ich mich als zivi genug um die alten
leute fragen gute kita geht es jetzt mit
angehört aber das wäre auch das wäre
auch so eine option also wie die jungen
die jungen müssen soldaten sein und kann
man dann nebenbei vielleicht auch den
mangel an kitaplätzen lösen
er verbindet das war der absolute also
gut dass sie keine politische
verantwortung tragen haben sie gedient
ein altes weiches sucht man jetzt ja
jede vorstellung jetzt noch ich bin gut
für den volkssturm also wenn nichts mehr
reicht dann kommen frauen und 60 plus
und dann leute vor allen dingen großen
passt auf was sache ist
[Applaus]
schauspielerin bekannt dass jugendliche
bevor sie entscheidungen treffen das
risiko wenig abwägen
aber das ist ja fürs militär optimal
eigentlich oder dass man sich fragt wo
vorsicht abhängen können sonst sagen sie
ja nachher nein ich will gleich auch ein
paar jugendliche rekrutieren ich gehe in
einem jugendzentrum haben sie dafür ich
so ein paar psychotricks sicherlich
sollten sie nicht mit fakten und
informationen argumentieren was
sinnvoller wäre es für jugendliche
adäquate anreizsysteme zu schaffen
mega so hat man sich beim zdf auch ein
köder dankeschön
hey bock auf krieg nein ok folgender dir
wenn ihr jetzt in 24 monats vertrag
abschließt kriegt ihr das neue iphone
dazu der empfang ist nicht immer gute
den krisengebieten aber besser als in
deutschland
ja ich brauche und ich mag samsung der
mann zu werden der ich nie war möchte
ich nicht wenn wir zurückkommen
aus dem krieg habt ihr krasse
geschichten zu erzählen also wenn er
zurückkommt muss man fairerweise sagen
also ja genau dieses wenn also ich
möchte erst wenn dann überhaupt
zurückkommen
smg ich in den krieg um coole
geschichten zu erzählen
ihr habt freie auswahl totaler jungs
überschuss es gibt sonst noch mal
maschinenbaustudium nämlich auch
soldaten
wir sind zu breit wie kann ich dir den
den bund irgendwie schmackhaft machen
habt ihr ein interesse an autogramm von
fabian köster ist dass ich der junge
lutz van dorst bär ist los wanderung
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok wo geht's hier raus
scheiße